>> Tucker: GETTING HARD TO
KEEP TRACK OF ALL THE THINGS
THAT ARE RACIST THESE DAYS.
JEFFERSON STATUES, MILK.
NOT WANTING
AFRICAN-AMERICANS TO ABORT
THEIR CHILDREN THAT'S
RACIST.
NOW ADD ANOTHER ONE TO THE
LONG LIST CAULIFLOWER IS
RACIST.
IN A VIDEO POSTED ON SUNDAY
YOUNG PIONEER ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ EXPLAINED TO
HER FOLLOWERS THAT IT IS
DEEPLY PROBLEM THAT THE
PARTICULAR TO GROW
CAULIFLOWER IN URBAN
GARDENS.
>> REALLY THINK ABOUT IT
WHEN SOMEONE SAYS THAT IT'S
TOO HARD TO DO A GREEN SPACE
THAT GROWS UCA INSTEAD OF, I
DON'T KNOW, CAULIFLOWER OR
SOMETHING, WHAT YOU ARE
DOING IS YOU ARE TAKING A
COLONIAL APPROACH TO
ENVIRONMENTALISM AND THAT IS
WHY A LOT OF COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR GET RESISTANCE TO
CERTAIN ENVIRONMENTALIST
MOVEMENT BECAUSE THEY COME
WITH A COLONIAL LENS ON
THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: EVEN ADJUSTING
FOR THE FACT SHE IS DUMB
WHICH SHE OBVIOUSLY IS IT'S
STILL CONFUSING.
WHAT IS SHE SAYING WE NEED
THE LIBERAL SHERPA TO FIGURE
IT OUT.
CATHY AREU FREQUENT GUEST ON
OUR SHOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: HOW RACIST IS
CAULIFLOWER AND LET ME JUST
TELL YOU I DON'T LIKE
CAULIFLOWER SO DON'T LOOK AT
ME LIKE I'M PART OF THE
CAULIFLOWER PROBLEM I'M NOT.
HOW RACIST IS IT?
>> THANK GOODNESS.
IT'S PART OF MONO CROPPING
SO ARE COLONIAL ANCESTORS
GREW COASTAL FLOWER SO
THEY'RE CROPPING THE SAME
OLD, SAME OLD VEGETABLES.
NOT GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE IT'S THE NAME
NUTRIENTS IN THE GROUND AND
IT ACTUALLY HURTS THE
ENVIRONMENT TO HAVE THE SAME
OLD SAME OLD SO THE CORN,
THE CAULIFLOWER,
COLONIALISM, SO SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT DIVERSIFYING
OUR VEGETABLES AS WE SHOULD
DIVERSIFY OUR CULTURE.
SO, UCA INSTEAD OF
CAULIFLOWER IS THE WAY TO GO
IF YOU DO NOT WANT TO BE
RACIST WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
COMMUNITY GARDENS.
>> Tucker: CALIFORNIA, YOU
MAKE A FAIR POINT.
CALL
CAULIFLOWER TOBACCO COMES
FROM INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF
AMERICANS AND SYPHILOUS TOO,
BY THE WAY.
>> BOTH ARE HEALTHY.
>> Tucker: WELL I DON'T KNOW
NOW.
TOBACCO IS AN INDIGENOUS
PLANT BUT YOU ARE SAYING
IT'S BAD BUT -- SO YOU ARE
SAYING TOBACCO IS WORSE THAN
CAULIFLOWER OR BETTER THAN
CAULIFLOWER.
>> THE TERM IS THE MONO
CROPPING.
IT'S THE GROWING THE SAME
THING IN OUR EARTH.
SO THERE ARE NO NUTRIENTS
THAT ARE BEING GIVEN TO OUR
LAND, SO, THEREFORE, IT
HURTS THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO IF WE GROW NEW THINGS SO
FORGET THE TOBACCO AND
CAULIFLOWER.
WE NEED THE NEW YUCCA
DIFFERENT PLANTS, DIFFERENT
CROPS BEING GROWN TO HELP
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
>> Tucker: THE CLIMATE PLAY
AS ROLE IN THIS.
SO I DON'T THINK YUCCA OR
PLANTANS GROW VERY WELL IN
BROOKLYN OR QUEENS.
>> HAVE YOU TRIED THOUGH?
HAVE YOU TRIED THOSE
COMMUNITY GARDENS ARE
USUALLY LED BY PEOPLE WITH
TIME ON THEIR HANDS.
THOSE UPPER CLASS WOMEN.
UPPER CLASS MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY TO HO HAVE TIME TO
VOLUNTEER NOT THOSE MIDDLE
CLASS WORKERS.
YEAH.
>> Tucker: THE RACIST
CAULIFLOWER EATERS.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
APPLYING SOCIAL JUSTICE
STANDARDS TO THE FOOD WE
EAT.
DO YOU THINK ULTIMATELY IT
MIGHT DRIVE US INSANE AND
CAUSE FOOD SHORTAGES?
>> I'M AFRAID.
WE NEED TO REALIZE THAT
SALSA IS MORE POPULAR THAN
KETCHUP.
IF WE WERE TRULY RACIST WE
WOULDN'T ALLOW SALSA IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE ARE A WONDERFUL COUNTRY
THAT ALLOWS DIVERSE FOOD AND
CROPS TO COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY AND WE CAN DIVERSIFY
OUR FOOD AND OUR CROPS.
YEAH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: EVERY TIME I GET
MAD AT THE LEFT I THINK IT
MUST BE LIVING HELL TO BE A
MEMBER OF IT BECAUSE YOU
WOULD HAVE TO REMEMBER ALL
THE RULES.
I DON'T THINK I COULD.
I'M TOO OLD.
>> IT'S NOT THAT HARD.
SALSA IS GOOD.
>> Tucker: IT'S BAFFLING TO